bitcoin mining the public miners are
down significantly uh you were telling a
lot of people that you were getting out
of mining stocks a few months ago what's
your general read right now on miners
and kind of the price drawdown that
they've experienced alongside the
drawdown in bitcoin price
well you remember
this this
problem started about a day after the
original memo from the sec
about five months ago talking about
carbon credits being audited
and so basically what's happened since
is
and this is a little complicated but
the data is is irrefutable now
when you set up a mining operation um
as we had multiple public miners last
year
uh they were being used as a proxy
by institutions to buy bitcoin because
the price of the mining shares whether
it was a hot aid or a riot or a marathon
um
and uh and many others uh really was in
was a great proxy for bitcoin volatility
you bought those shares bitcoin goes up
the shares went up bitcoin goes down the
shares go down it was almost a perfect
correlation regardless of how many
megawatts each of these companies had
mining nobody cared about the source of
power at that time
but then along came that memo when
basically what it said is look if you're
a public company you've got to get your
auditors to sign your public statements
and we're going to add a little
attribute
if we have our way we're going to
actually if you're using carbon credits
or offsets we're going to have you sign
that too
and basically what the scc was saying is
they were calling bs on carbon credits
so many companies said look yeah i'm
using coal or flared gas to to mine
bitcoin but i bought an acre of the
amazon it's got a thousand trees so it's
an offset well the sec said
get me an auditor to sign that so if you
call any of the big five audit firms
they're not going to sign that because
there's no ledger to carbon credits
it was that day and i won't forget it
when i started getting calls from the
larger sovereign and institutional
accounts that were using the index
to strategize holding bitcoin by holding
the public miners
and wow were they dumping stock so
i mean
they read the writing on the wall
a lot of these companies are going to
face bankruptcy because they levered
their bitcoin mining
borrowed money to you know build more
facilities and they're offside 50 60
plus leverage
but the bigger problem pomp is this
let's say you want to raise new capital
because i'm in the mining business and i
want to raise let's say you're going to
do a 300 megawatt facility
in a friendly state like north dakota or
montana or south carolina where you can
get power you can get a plug in for less
than four cents a kilowatt hour which is
what you need to be globally competitive
you have to find a power source behind
the meter in other words where you can
prove to someone that you are compliant
from a carbon perspective and that
really points to nuclear power and hydro
power so all of a sudden places like
northern norway where we have a facility
being built in a company called bizzero
where behind the meter every electron
comes from a giant hydro dam no need for
a carbon audit and we're able to raise
money because the institutions that
provide the funding whether it be debt
or equity understand there's no risk
take any other public minor ask them
where their power comes from they say
it's blended they don't know basically
and that's the problem the existing
miners have in a way they're kind of
screwed but i think a new generation of
miners emerging i'm not the only guy
doing this there's other funds out there
that are basically finding hydro and
nuclear power and regenerating this
industry from scratch at a carbon zero
footprint it's not just bitcoin mining
it's ethereum it's any data center
this is going to be the issue going
forward so the older miners
their stocks are down 70 to 90 percent
not coming back
sorry
kevin is it your belief that many
bitcoin miners should go and start using
nuclear power to mine bitcoin
yes absolutely and hydropower there's no
question about it what if there's excess
power there's no better way to store the
value than mining there's no better way
and so the mining industry which has
taken such a bad bad bad pr
extremely bad pr in the last six months
it couldn't be worse getting accused of
every disease known to man
they're actually doing something very
important they're advancing technology
and mining technology and semiconductor
technology and heat technology every
generation every 36 months later there's
a new technology that's more efficient
in terms of mining which is a good thing
for everybody else and also they're
taking excess power let's go back to
norway in the 50s they built so much
hydroelectricity that over half of it's
never used it goes over the dam and it's
never used now with bitcoin mining these
miners can go into those communities and
create jobs data centers excess heat is
doing hydroponic growth there because
they're in basically an arctic climate
and storing value by creating bitcoin
paying taxes in norway they don't get
thrown out of the country they're
embraced by the government there because
they see the imputed value look at what
happened in new york all of that power
going over niagara falls is being wasted
because no bitcoin miners can set up
there the government's gone berserk and
chased all the capital out of there in
fact that norway project started in
upstate new york and after the
government went wonky on policy in that
state moved all of the mining facility
to norway where they're accepted so
there's a lot of differences between
policy in different states you've got to
go find the ones that are willing to
embrace the concept
of mining for the reasons that it has
merit which is basically to store value
in unused power hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time